data science has become a big buzzword
in the business world today companies
have been actively hiring data
scientists Python developers and machine
learning engineers to build data science
teams in order to capitalize on the vast
volumes of data that these companies
generate daily business managers realize
that there's value in the data that they
have access to often though they are
just not sure how to extract it and
achieve meaningful business impact and
this is confirmed by a recent Garten
study which reported that 85% of all
data science projects fail to understand
why this is the case let's look at the
results of a survey run by cago last
year the survey had a question on the
biggest challenges that businesses faced
in their data science efforts the survey
identified 15 most common data science
challenges these 15 challenges can be
grouped into four distinct categories
the first category deals with data
almost half of the respondents reported
the impure data as the ultimate top
challenge also we learn that obtaining
data for the data science projects might
be hard
besides privacy issues post specific
challenges to you'll probably come as no
surprise to anyone familiar with data
science projects to see data related
issues as the major hurdle the second
category of challenges is related to
human factor over 40% of the survey
participants feel that there's a
shortage of the qualified data science
engineers in the field besides it is
evident that communication and
collaboration is another major issue
implementing data science projects
usually involves three main stakeholders
business IT and of course data science
this survey shows there are clear issues
of collaboration and communication
between these camps lack of managerial
support lack of clear questions to
address results are not used or
implemented by the business difficulty
deploying and coordinating with IT and
difficulty explaining data science the
third category of challenges identified
by the survey was related to limitations
of available tools most data science
tools reach their limits relatively
quickly
which forces machine learning engineers
to create custom developed code in order
to optimize the computing time required
to run the models the fourth category of
challenges was linked to lack of
financial support of the data science
projects almost 40 percent of the
respondents answered that the lack of
financial support hinders their data
science efforts this becomes a major
issue especially when the data science
projects grow big and the size of the
data you're using in the projects is
usually positively correlated with the
cost the bigger the data the more
difficult it is to control the costs as
a result the companies need to employ
more expensive technology stack more
expensive talent and more computing
power
in order to improve the odds of
achieving a positive ROI of a data
science project businesses need to be
aware of these challenges and find means
of addressing them effectively